So now that we know that cache blocks
need to be at aligned memory addresses,
let's look at what the memory and
cache look like in terms of blocks.
Our memory can be seen as just
a huge array of memory locations.
Let's say this is location number 0.
And let's say that each
location is 4 bytes wide.
So the next location is at address 4.
And then 8, and so on.
Let's say that our
block size is 16 bytes.
That means that a possible
block in memory is this.
This would be the first block.
This would be the second block.
This would be the third block,
and so on.
A cache, then, can be considered to be
a number of slots where a block can fit.
In this case,
we have just a two-block cache.
So, the cache size is just
equal to two block sizes.
So memory has blocks of data,
and our cache
has lines which are basically
slots where a block can fit.
We can say, for example,
that block number 0 can be
fetched into the cache and
placed in line number 0.
So when we want to make
a precise distinction between
the space in the cache where
we can put a block and
the actual memory content we put there,
the space in the cache is called a line.
And the stuff we put
there is called a block.
The line size and
the block size are the same.
So a line is effectively a slot
where a block might fit.